the following content is provided under
a Creative Commons license your support
will help MIT OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high quality educational resources
for free
to make a donation or to view additional
materials from hundreds of MIT courses
visit MIT opencourseware at ocw.mit.edu
last kind of under the announcements
category is I want to talk about the
muddy cards so I've used those many
times in the past last time it was the
first time I handed him out and your
comments were great this is really a
nice I didn't see it with a good lecture
to have handed them out we can cover
lots of interesting kinds of important
concepts and but I'm so I'm going to
review a couple of things that came up
in the muddy cards the couple of the
most positive comments is people really
liked the demos and the really liked the
explanations especially with the example
with examples particularly people
particularly commented it was really
helpful to compute angular momentum from
two different points and get the
revelation that you get two very
different answers so that's a really
important really important point and
somebody then asks the question said
well I thought the vectors were
independent of the coordinate system
that you select that's true you know a
velocity ought to be a velocity no
matter whether it's our theta or XYZ but
why that seems to kind of violate that
notion that vectors are have should be
independent of coordinates and yet we
computed an angular momentum with
respect to one place in respect to a
different place and we got different
answers do you think how do you resolve
that
okay getting close I'll I'll little bit
let me here's here was the problem I
think we did and we chose this point
which I'll call - and this point which I
have called one and we computed H of 1
with respect to point 1 we'll call this
a we computed a with respect to 1 and we
computed the angular momentum of a with
respect to 2 but in this case angular
momentum of a particle with respect to
some location origin of a coordinate
system is defined as R of the particle
with respect to the coordinate system
crossed with the linear momentum of the
particle that year we'll call it B here
is the name of the particle the
definition these are both vectors you
are changing the vector it is a
different vector because this this
changes in the two parts so it's not a
constant vector at all you've chained by
its definition it is just something
different when you move to a different
place and this piece changes this piece
is invariant but this piece is not and
that's it that's the answer to that one
lots of people were still not clear
about Coriolis I will work on that as
time goes by and people were interested
and you know how to fix how to pick
reference frames and so forth somebody
made the suggestion try using some color
chalk it would help I don't know any
color talk my secretary my good my
assistant you'd walk in with some she
found some of the last minute so I'll
try doing that that's a good idea and
someone else says take a break in an
hour and that's a pretty good idea -
I'll try to remember to do that so the
muddy cards are great please today do
the same we'll do the same thing so
let's start
with this topic this
the subject which is constantly
constantly used throughout the course
doing dynamics you have to be able to
figure out coordinate systems degrees of
freedom drawing free body diagrams so
I'm going to do a few quick examples
coordinates FPDs emphasize I'm picking a
pick some examples here just to
emphasize a few different a few
different points here we have a slope
I've got a wheel it's a rigid body I
pick a preliminary coordinate system
sometimes you do that just to help you
think about it and now let's talk about
degrees of freedom what do we mean by
degrees of freedom I'm going to define
it as the number of independent
coordinates
necessary to describe the motion so it's
the number of independent coordinates
that you need okay now for with you with
few exceptions I can compute that by
multiplying six times the number of
rigid bodies in the problem plus three
times the number of particles minus the
constraints the number of constraints so
this is the number of rigid bodies this
is the number of particles and see this
is a constraints
so in this take a look at this problem a
wheels a rigid body the difference
between a rigid body and a particle the
rigid bodies big enough it has mass at
some extent it's rotational inertia will
matter so here we've got a wheel so
we've got certainly one rigid body but
no particles so in this case n is one M
zero and so the number of degrees of
freedom that we should come up with in
this problem it's going to look like six
minus C and so then the problem becomes
let's identify what the constraints are
in the problem so I drew my initial
little coordinate system just so that I
could I can used language like XY and z
direction so Z's coming out of the board
so in this problem let's let's figure
out how many constraints are
how about the y-direction the simplest
kind of constraints if things are just
allow no motion gonna move in the Y
direction no ok so YY dot y double dot
are zero that's that's a hard constraint
can't move through through the wall in
the y-direction we make we assume to
make you make a lot of us have to make
assumptions when you're doing problems
you try to simplify things as much as
you can so that you make them easy so
we're really a I'm gonna zoom in this
problem I haven't shown any constraints
or wheelers they're guides or rollers
but I'm gonna assume they won't move in
the Z direction so that's another
constraint so this is a flies one this
implies another constraint if I don't do
this if I don't assume that then I just
have end up with another equation of
motion for every degree of freedom
you'll end up with a problem you're
going to need an equation of motion so
if I did not make this assumption I'd
say that the summation of the forces in
the Z Direction is equal to zero and
that's equal to the mass times the
acceleration in the body in the Z dizzi
acceleration it's a vector vector
component and then you just say oh well
that's a trivial equation of motion and
so you could deal with that way but
we'll just assume that we have no motion
in the Z and that gives us another
constraint now we can assume again that
there's constraints in the problem or
its well behaved in that we won't get
the thing won't fall over it won't roll
over and it won't change direction
running down the hill so it will assume
no rotation
about the X or Y axes okay so that
implies two more constraints finally the
strength constraints come in can kind of
many flavors finally we know that in
this problem that I'll put in I need to
think in terms of a rotation so there's
a positive rotation in that coordinate
system so now I have a rotational
coordinate that I can think about and
but this now says that if there's no
slip I can say that the distance it
rolls down the hill
it's minus our favorite that's a
constraint X and data are not
independent of one another these we're
looking for the number of independent
coordinates required to completely
describe the motion x and r are not
independent because of this no slip
condition and so that implies yet
another okay so we've got one two three
four five constraints and we said that
the number of degrees of freedom in this
problem hang over six minus five one so
it takes a single coordinate you could
have told me that long ago that that's
what I'm gonna take but this is just
sort of thinking you have to go through
to come up with all these constraints so
this is going to take a single
coordinate it could be X it could be
theta but you don't need actually need
them both you use them both for a while
because it's convenient but the final
analysis you'll be able to write an
equation of motion just in terms of X or
just in terms of theta okay three body
diagrams
of our wheel we said no we said no slip
so here's your slope you know you got mg
you know there's going to be a normal
force from the slope there may also be
some tangential force that makes it
impossible for it not to slip some F so
there's a free body diagram in this case
what if I'll do e here or do case two
here slip allowed then how many
constraints do we have just forward
because now you can no longer say that
this is true they're independent of one
another they take on values not
controlled by this formulation it's a
6-4 it gives you two and you're going to
end up having to have both X and theta
probably as your chosen coordinates to
do the problem and you'll end up two
equations of motion
so I've got a hockey puck here on a
drone kind of kind of a 3d perspective
of this so it has a coordinate system
out here the z-axis is going like that
so here's my Z here's my X here's my Y
in the plane of the ice that this thing
is sliding on okay so this is my Z
coordinate and I have string wrapped
around it and I've got a piece of string
coming off like that and I'm pulling on
it there's some tension it's otherwise
you know the only constraints are it's
sitting on this icy surface which I'm
going to assume is well they don't even
have to assume it's frictional and
frictionless I could so let's figure out
how many equations of motion we're going
to need here so the number of degrees of
freedom six times this is a rigid body
it's not a particle and there's only one
of them right so it's six times one
minus C and the number of constraints so
can it move into the table into the onto
the surface no so that's a constraint
Izzie are there any constraints in the X
in X or Y it can rotate about Z but it
can't rotate about the X or Y axis all
right so get straight into Z is one
can't rotate about X X or Y - 3 are
there any others
[Music]
they can miss anybody who thinks I'm man
miss one okay
I'd say we've got 6-3 we're gonna need
three equations of motion to cover the
to be able to actually describe the
motion of this thing and we'd probably
use this is a pretty pretty good
coordinate system we'd probably use an X
a Y and some theta with respect to z
axis all right another quick example
so we've got a rod leaning against the
wall its length L do that it's L long
I've got a center of mass here at the
middle uniform rod let this be X Y Z
coming out of the board maybe give it an
angle here just to help describe motions
you know you might start off with a
preliminary little coordinate system
just that you can think that okay no
motion in the ax no rotation in this but
once you get the problem you ready to
set up the equations of motion you might
decide okay I know I need two
coordinates and the ones I preliminary
chosen aren't too good then you change
and you pick the really good ones but
I'm just making this preliminary
assessment so I can assess the problem
here again the degrees of freedom 6
times 1 minus e because I only have one
rigid body now
what this the constraints here are a
little more subtle let's discuss these
two points what can you say about the
motion at Point a this is right here
where it touches the wall this thing
sliding down the wall might be
frictionless might not whether or not
friction acts doesn't really change the
number of degrees of freedom unless you
invoke things like no slip what can you
say that you can kinematically about
motion about the motion at a dazz the
wall restrict the motion in one
so is this in which direction is this
body constrained in the x-direction
pardon
how do you know I hear some yeses this
is what about Abby
is it constrained that B in the Y
directions okay I didn't bring my large
my big foam disc but earlier in the term
I said that the definition of
translation is that all points on a
rigid body do what if the you are in
rectilinear or curvilinear translation
as opposed to rotation they all points
move in parallel exactly right that
means that we have we used real strict
definitions of translation and rotation
that if I can strain the motion of any
point on that object that object is now
not allowed to translate in that
direction by the definition of
translation so this this point can
strains it in the X direction this
constraints it in the Y direction and
we're going to so it has its constrained
in translation
and that implies two and B will assume
that Y excuse me that Z motion is zero
we'll just assume there's nothing going
on out of the plane so that gives me
another one okay and I'll assume no
rotation not going to allow any rotation
in this problem not interested rotation
about the ax or about the Y about these
axes and that implies two more so I have
two three four five and I better not
have any more than that oh the thing can
move all right so in this case this is
six minus five equals one I need a
single coordinate to describe the motion
if you look at it you say that's kind of
intuitive go out obvious if I specify
the x position here I could figure
everything out if I know the length and
the axis I could figure out where it is
I know the the Y position and the length
I could figure out where it is by no
theta I could figure that I only need
one but that strict definition of
translation is really helpful here this
thing this object is in pure rotation if
it's in pure rotation it must rotate it
about a some point where you know how to
find that what's the velocity here
it's got gravity acting on it so it's
probably down right but it's parallel
wall has to be what's the velocity here
it's got to be parallel to the wall if I
draw a perpendicular to that if I'm
assuming if I'm saying this is rotation
rotation all points in the body rotate
at the same rate but their speed
is determined by their distance away
from from the center of rotation but
their money if it's a pure rotation
there must be a center of rotation
somewhere and it must be perpendicular
to any velocity vector so you drive it
perpendicular you draw the perpendicular
and here is the instantaneous center of
rotation the ICR there's a little short
section in the book on that when the
thing drops down to here same kind of
arguments hold but the center of
rotation has changed locations yeah
yeah so now now let's talk about the
center of mass so she asked is it excuse
me I should repeat the question
you guys aren't holding me that very
well raise your hands if I don't repeat
the important question she says is it
not translating we've determined that
let me ask you does the center of mass
move in this Newton's second law apply
to the motion of the center of mass
yeah it's kind of so the center-of-mass
translates no doubt about that Newton's
second law applies to it okay
so we're not saying that there isn't
motion of the system in the x and y
we're just saying that that motion is
caused by rotation it's not caused by
what is strictly defined this
translation Freebody diagram the reason
let's think about a Freebody diagram for
this here's our rod there must be if
it's I'll let it be frictionless to make
the keep the problem simple for a moment
that means there must be just a normal
force in the x-direction here I'll call
it an X and there must be a normal force
in the Y oh and why center mass there
must be an mg but so now that I set the
problem up this way how many unknowns
are there in the problem if I want to
calculate literally the motion of this
thing so finding the equation of motion
to solve it how many unknowns do I have
how many I hear one I see two on the
board but it's to the right answer I
hear three who said three all right
what's the third one
how do you describe acceleration with a
[Music]
coordinate of some kind right there's
another unknown it's probably the thing
that you're trying to solve for it's
actually the motion itself right
describe my theta or X or Y whatever you
do
there's at least three unknowns in this
problem the way it's way you see it in
this e in this free body diagram so
you've got to figure out ways around
that this instantaneous center of
rotation gives you one possible way
around that because about an
instantaneous Center it's not moving
it's a it's an axis it's not moving how
we have a little formula that says the
time rate of change of angular momentum
torque is related to the time rate of
change of angular momentum and you can
have a messy formula or not so messy and
it's not so messy when the axis of
rotation is stationary so at this
instant in time the axis is stationary
you can say that the torques about this
point the ICR summation of the torques
with respect
the ICR is equal to d this is now a
rigid body with respect to the ICR DT
okay and what are in this problem what
are the torques
where do the torques come from is there
any torque caused by an X no there's no
motor right pointing right at the center
same thing no cooked or caused by this
you want to find equations that get rid
of unknown so you don't neither unknown
appears in this equation where's the
torque come from gravity right and it's
gonna be some mg times a moment arm and
the moment arm is going to be like that
so it's an L over 2 sine theta and the
sine you'll have to figure out from an
hour cross an F so you have a I cross J
gives you a K but it's in the -
directions I think it'll come out - but
I could be wrong I did that kind of fat
did that on the fly so we're not gonna
go further with this but an
instantaneous centers of rotation could
be really handy okay a final example
yeah in this stuff yeah we do it on time
couple of carts so the floor constrains
the motion and I've got a spring and a
dashpot and m1 and an M - I want to
figure out how many yeah it's just a
you're saying why is the torque negative
I this is the R is L over two in the I
hat right and the gravity cross with the
force which is mg in the but it's minus
mg in the J hat so I cross J is positive
K but the minus sign comes from there
well I'm working on the center of mass
here that's my equation and this thing
is hell long so half of the length must
be L over two and I'm interested in this
side of the right triangle cross where
that gives me zero there's no moment so
this is a moment equation trying to
compute moments yeah it's got to be
about the ICR so the force is down ooh
it's got to be this one I messed up good
catch so that's a cosine right still L
over two
you got a theta this is also theta
now for this side and that's good okay
got to keep rolling I got something else
really fun I want to talk about so let's
do this example quickly this is mostly
to get you to think about Freebody
diagrams this to rigid bodies the juries
are freedom quickly here six times two
there's no particles minus C so twelve
minus C now how many what's your
intuition tell you how many independent
coordinates is are going to take this
all this product hold it on there I see
two one two one two
well I think it's good there's 10 you
can find 10 constraints in this problem
if you assume it doesn't roll over and
you doesn't move you can find 10 you're
going to need two coordinates because
just because you got a spring in a
dashpot they don't fix they don't say
there's any particular relation between
the motion of this and the motion of
that you're going to need an independent
coordinate to describe the whoops 2
times 6 is 12 minus 10 you don't need
any you need an independent coordinate
to describe the motion of each of these
masses and I'd probably choose a
coordinate that let's say goes from the
center of mass of this one I'll call it
X 1 center of mass of this one I'll call
it X 2 and because I've been doing
problems vibration problems and stuff
that goes for a long time and it's I'll
tell you it's smart to start your
coordinates at zero when you have 0
spring forces or from the static
equilibrium position that's the good
place to start so then your answer if
you're at the static equilibrium
position then any nonzero answers that
come out of it are movement around that
point that's that's what Mother Nature
does you know you spring hanging on a
mass hanging on a spring it has a static
equilibrium position the vibration
occurs around it your car sitting on the
ground the vibrations it's around its
static equilibrium position so you
usually choose these at the static
equilibrium and you'll find that that
makes for much for simpler equilibria
you'll find that it makes for the
simplest equation to motion they tend to
be not have constants on the right hand
side that's caused by gravity or offsets
or things like that so this thing you're
gonna this is this actually a problem
very similar this is on your homework
you have
the homework says go find what these ten
are so you could name them pretty fast
that's why I'm not doing it for you what
I do want to do quickly here is just
talk about how you assign
how you free body diagrams for this
problem because people one of the most
easiest thing together to get confused
about its figuring out the directions of
the forces that have that come from the
springs and dashpots
in which direction accent so each so
I've made my X's so that they're at X is
X 1 is 0 when this thing's at its static
equilibrium position and I'm going to
start by assuming that X 1 and X 1 dot
are positive you just establish positive
motions and you deduce the direction of
the spring and dashpot forces
okay so and you do them one at a time
these are the problems we're doing here
our linear spring force is equal to KX
dashpot forces our BX dot so they're
linear problems so this superposition
holds you can just do these conceptually
one at a time and figure them out and
then you add them all together to get
the complete answer so if I have life x1
moves in the positive direction what is
the direction that that spring puts on
this mass as a result which direction is
it my ordnance system is in a positive
here's x1 will do the same thing here
here's x2 so if it moves in the positive
direction out to here what what is the
spring gonna say it do no other motion
allowed in the system
just that one it moves a little bit
what's the spring do on that mass okay
x1 and I let the sign be indicated by
the direction of the arrow and I'll use
that when I write out my equation of
motion okay now I'm going to assume a
positive B x1 so it's velocity in that
direction what's the dashpot do another
force here be x1 dot all right now I'm
still this is if you have two bodies you
have to have two Freebody diagrams one
for each but I need to know what's the
effect of x1 x2 and x2 dot on this body
well let's just go do the same thing
let's let X to be positive now it's the
only motion I have a positive movement
of x2 that stretches the spring
what is that spring force do apply to
this what direction is it in
just by moving the back way which way to
spring it and pull on this okay ok x2
and a positive velocity to the right hey
what's the step makes the dashpot open
up what direction is the force that
dashpot puts on this B x2 dot and now in
this problem except for gravity I've got
a normal force up and an mg down but all
the action all the motion is in the
horizontal direction I can write out an
equation of motion for the first the
first rigid body here and that's the sum
of the forces in the X direction on body
one I'll give us it one here in the X is
equal to m1 x1 double dot and now I can
just write it out it is K x2 because
that one's positive minus x1 plus B X 2
dot minus x1 dot and that has the signs
right and now Cole key is just one at a
time assume positive emotions and deduce
what happens and then use the arrows the
direction of the arrow is to set the
signs and now there's your equation of
motion now we could do the same thing
sum of the forces on two in the X 2
direction
M 2 X 2 double dot and now we would do
exactly the same thing so positive
motion of X 1 what does it do over here
you can force through the spring in
which direction ok X 1 be X 1 dot and
you'll find that okay X to be X 2 dot
and you sum it up and you'll end up this
should switch around okay X 1 minus X 2
plus B X 1 dot 2 minus X 2 dot ok you've
got two equations of motion and they're
mixed so they have each one has both
coordinates in it so these are this
problem is two questions emotional than
a couple they're not independent you
have to solve them together ok now we're
going to move on to a subject which has
to come up in conversation people have
asked about this lots of times and they
say what about you know what about a
centrifugal force and that you sometimes
use the term fictitious force how many
of you use the word the word used
fictitious force and how many times how
many of you heard us say that
centripetal acceleration is not a force
it's an acceleration and yet we love to
talk about this concept of centrifugal
force which doesn't exist but a trips us
all up because it's handy to think about
it and so I can't talk about we're going
to talk about fictitious forces now
they're handy but they are dangerous you
really have to understand your
fundamentals if you're going to use the
concept if fictitious forces without
getting yourself in trouble okay what is
a fictitious force well Newton's law and
start there
Newton's second sum of the forces
external on the body equals the mass
times acceleration two vector equation
we can break it down into its components
so a fictitious force
you take the true acceleration
time's the mass so yeah fictitious force
is when you take multiply the true
acceleration times the mass and put it
on the summation of forces side of the
equation that's really all it is and you
move it over to this side of the
equation and you think of it as a force
so what you've done is you've said that
the summation of the forces minus ma is
to move it over here you got to subtract
it from this side equals 0 and you're
saying I'm just gonna think of this as a
force and it makes this whole equation
be conveniently equal to 0 but now so
that's you know that's kind of abstract
let's see if we can figure out a example
or two to illustrate this
I'm sure you've done this problem that
physics is gonna pick a really
elementary problem so you don't get hung
up on the physics to start with this is
the elevator problem you've got cables
pulling it up you've got some scales in
here and you're standing on it
here's your center of mass we'll call
that a and the excel and the the I need
a coordinate system my inertial system
Newton's law only applies in inertial
systems so here's my X I call this Z and
I'll call this Y so I need to write an
equation of motion about this person
riding up in the elevator we take a look
at it how many degrees of freedom all
sorts of constraints it's only going up
so we're gonna say we need one at 1
degree of freedom Freebody diagram well
there's this object has some force
pushing up on it this this is my this is
the person this is your mass it has a
force pulling down on it mg and that's
it okay now this ends gonna work out to
be with the scales read right it's
coming through the scales that's really
what we're looking for
and the problem here is to find the
weight in the scales so we say that the
summation of the forces in the
y-direction and in this problem we would
say it's the mass times the acceleration
of point a with respect to O and the sum
of those forces you got an N minus mg
and that's pretty simple equation now
I'm going to specify given that
acceleration of a with respect to O is a
quarter of a G so that's the cables in
the elevator doing its making this thing
move and it's going up at a quarter of a
G in acceleration so it's getting faster
and faster okay so if I solve this for n
I will get stop there
and it's normally what I would just do
but since we're talking about its
fictitious horses I needed Goethe I
needed to go through that step for a
second so now I say that well the summit
and the forces in the y-direction here
minus M acceleration of a with respect
to O is equal that total is equal to
zero and that then is n minus mg minus M
times G over four right and now ice now
I have taken this upward acceleration
and I've treated it like a force and
just moved it to this other side set the
whole thing equal to 0 this is the
fictitious force I'm gonna say okay
that's all the force in the system solve
for in and of course you get in is M
times G Plus G over 4 and that's 5/4 mg
and so you read 25% heavier it's a
really trivial example but this the
notion is that you think of this as an a
force that's been applied it's the mass
times the acceleration with a minus sign
in front of it it'll always turn out
like that it's minus the mass times the
acceleration now the acceleration can
come from Coriolis acceleration it can
come from centripetal acceleration so if
we do this in a rotating thing this
fictitious force might be the
centrifugal force force which is minus M
times the centripetal acceleration and
we'll do an example like that
[Applause]
alright okay trivial example let's see
if we can find something a little harder
how we doing on time we're doing pretty
good
so let's do an example where this where
the notion is really quite powerful now
I showed you this last time and we
talked a lot about we did the time
derivative of the angular momentum and
we computed the torques that this thing
exerts around different axes right with
respect to the point of attachment with
this well this is an example of which if
you're comfortable with fictitious
forces you can figure out those torques
really corral it quickly so I'm going to
these two problems are identical this
problem or with a shaft running like
that are really exactly identical but
I'm going to pretend that my thing is
made this way because it makes it easier
to see where these torques are coming
from so here's my Z and I've got my
rotation about the z axis here's this
mass okay my coordinates here's my R hat
here's my ZK hat is this distance here
and this is I'm gonna set conditions in
the problem my rotation rate it's also
theta dot about the K z-axis and Omega
dot theta double dot also in the K it's
not restricted so I'm allowing this
thing to accelerate but r dot equals R
double dot is zero so it's not changing
a position it's just fixed and I need to
figure out the forces on this thing and
and talk about how we might consider
some of them as fictitious forces so
let's think about in the r direction
summation of the forces here in this r
hat or
action so it's one vector component I
don't have to carry along all the all of
the other baggage it's equal to and I
better give these I'll call this B this
is going to be the point about which I
care about things there's a fixed
coordinate system here o X Y Z but then
a rotating coordinate system we'll call
this a and it's going to have my
coordinates I'll use polar coordinates
so R theta Z but this one rotates but it
also has its origin right there
coincident with O so the sum in the r
direction then we have the mass times
the acceleration of B with respect to O
and the acceleration of B with respect
to O is the acceleration of will just
write out the whole formula using pole
using cylindrical coordinates R double
dot minus R theta dot squared this is in
the R hat plus R theta double dot plus 2
r dot theta dot in the theta hat
direction that's my full expression for
it whips not quite full forgot a term
right there we go that's my full
expression for acceleration using
cylindrical coordinates but with with a
moving possibly translating and rotating
reference frame this piece here accounts
for what
in Jena why do we have that turn
it's the translational acceleration of
the a-frame right so we can account for
in this case what is that okay so this
term is zero but you need to you know
this formula you really need to know
because it accounts for all of the
accelerations in the problem you know
that you just go in and start assigning
picking out things what's this zero is
this arrow no how about this one this
one definitely zero and this one zero
I don't have many terms left from this
alright so this then is the mass times
minus R theta dot squared and this is R
hat plus R theta double dot in the theta
hat direction now I said I was summing
the forces in the r I put all of them in
at the moment maybe let's let's maybe
smarter to do that let me reverse course
here
this is the vector summation of all the
forces for a moment and then we'll take
the arc huh well just we'll take the R
component next so just the R component
the summation of the forces in the are
we look at this and we say oh it's just
that minus M R theta dot squared okay
all right so that's and that's the r
direction but now we need a Freebody
diagram and yeah the so in my in our
direction this is my acceleration that's
the only acceleration in the r direction
it's what we know to be centripetal
right and the - tells us its inward
Freebody diagram I need that so looking
you know a side view
there's your bead there is I'm gonna
draw it as an unknown here there's an
unknown force in the r direction that
comes from this bar holding it is
applying its there's got to be a force
that makes this go in a circle
and that bar is the what provides it
it's the only thing hook in there and
I've just called this unknown n R and
I'm just drawing it in the positive
direction they mostly in a way you can
do this if you're not sure the direction
draw it positive and the sign will tell
you it was a sign that falls out tells
you what the right answer is there'll be
some force in the Z provided by the rod
they'll be an mg and that should be it
if we did a top for you then there'd be
an unknown in the theta direction
there'd be a you'd also see the end in
the r direction and anything else no the
mg is down where you can't see it so
these are your two free body diagrams
okay so now listen so then this
direction this is the acceleration and
the external forces or is just that so
the sum of the forces is in R now I'd
like to I want to treat it I'll bring in
this concept of fictitious force
I'm going to move move the acceleration
term to the other side
and our unknown positive now I'm going
to move that acceleration term over here
- ah but now it's - the acceleration so
this term looks like that has a minus
sign and move it over here that actually
becomes plus okay
equals zero now this is your fictitious
force sometimes people call them inertia
forces and it acts like it's pullin out
on the object so the force that that the
mass appears to apply through the rod is
this centrifugal force pullin out so of
course now we could solve for NR and we
find it's a - M R theta dot squared
which we knew all along it's the force
applied to the mass by the arm as it
spins around it has to pull in on it to
make it go in that circle okay now and
you're gonna we can do the same thing in
the theta direction the theta direction
will have an M R theta double dot and we
look at the afaid equation of motion I
mean D theta Freebody diagram it's + n
theta you could solve that and you can
immediately come up with a a solution
for the force in the theta direction I'm
just gonna write that one down
that one will this one sulfurous when
you get a minus sign this one ends up +
M R theta double dot I'm not going to go
through the McKenna know the gyrations
of getting to this you can do that one
now I want to do
[Music]
quick thing with this this is where once
you develop confidence in knowing when
you can use it a fictitious force and
not get in trouble this is the sort of
thing you might do here's my system it's
rotating and I want a quick estimate of
the what's the torque
what's the bending moment about this
point caused by that the fact that it is
of the centripetal acceleration
well centripetal acceleration is
equivalent to having this fictitious
force outward on this of an amount M R
theta dot squared and this is the moment
arm Z what's the torque that that causes
about this point
because this is your lepers now forces a
lever and I've got that centrifugal
force pulling out on the stick Tisha's
force yeah the moment the torque about
this point caused by that torque at O is
minus M R theta dot squared times Z the
moment arm and it's not - it's in that
direction so it's plus tinda theta hat
direction
the torque that that force is applying
about this point is that if you if we
could have told this problem the way we
did in the last lecture very carefully
going through the DHD T's and following
it all out and we would have gotten that
answer for the torque except for a minus
sign now why the difference this is the
torque that this centripetal force
causes down here the when you do dhdt
you get the torque required to make
what's happening happen it's just the
opposite this this this is the torque
this is putting about that there must be
an equal and opposite torque that this
system puts on this arm out here to keep
it from flopping out so this is applying
a torque here it must resist with a
torque and so when you do D dhdt
you're gonna end up with a minus M R
theta dot squared theta hat okay so you
got to be careful using you know what
your what you mean but you can but from
an engineering point of view if I were
just trying to calculate the bending
moment down here and deciding whether or
not this shaft could sticking out here
is going to break off or not I could
make a very quick estimate at the
depending moment by knowing is central
force times the moment arm yeah all
right so now is there there we could
also we have a theta Direction thing
here right there's a we could think of a
fictitious force in the theta direction
and that was the M R theta double dot
term does it generate does it generate
torques that you could completely
compute so as this thing is trying to
accelerate in the pot you know positive
acceleration Omega dot theta double dot
it's trying to accelerate into the board
the bar is having to push that thing
into the board there's a force in the
positive theta hat direction but the the
fictitious inertial force is the mass
pushing back on the rod pushing this way
M R theta double dot pushing this way
what moments does that cause about this
point
so if you have a force this way now the
force in they'll call it the theta
Direction is M R theta double dot now
this is my fictitious force all right
this is this fictitious force it's in
the minus theta hat direction it's
resist it's it's pushing back it's in
the minus theta hat direction to M R
theta double dot and a torque is some R
cross with the force and this our R is
that are the a and it's composed of our
R hat and Z K hat here so we have to do
a little our r hat plus Z K hat crossed
with minus M R theta double dot theta
hat so you get an R cross R hat cross
theta hat gives you a k a k cross theta
hat gives you an R you're gonna get two
terms out of this one is going to look
like M R squared theta double dot and
that's a torque and the other ones and
that is the one that it takes to that's
the that's the torque about this axis
there's a force times this moment arm
that's a torque about this axis that's
the actual torque it takes to speed this
thing up okay and then there's a torque
about this axis which is this length
times this force and that's the other
term that will give you the term in the
r direction it'll be a twist
it'll be trying to twist this bar like
that because there's a force in this
direction yeah
Smike the forces are real but they're
the force I mean this is this is why a
fictitious forces this concept of them
is so dangerous is because it's it's
really tempting just start thinking of
them like real forces so anytime you get
stuck you go back to the basics and you
say Newton's law F equals MA
you see torques is dhdt Plus that V
cross P term if you need it and you work
it out carefully using all the vector
math and then you are dealing old and
then Coriolis centripetal Euler terms
are only accelerations you treat them as
pure accelerations that's all they are
okay now to cause accelerations you need
to apply forces and these are and these
we give these forces names because it's
helpful conceptually to think about
these things as forces sometimes but
they are not real forces okay but you
can but it's quick and you if you get
too comfortable with them they are great
assets to your intuition so I know
immediately just looking at this thing
as soon as I see a machine that has a
part that rotates like this I see
rotational motion that's central in our
circular motion must be the equivalent
of a centrifugal force pull that this
mass is gonna pull in that direction
because it's going round and round and
it's gonna cause a moment about this
thing I didn't know for sure that's got
to be there if I'm gonna do it
rigorously I call it centripetal
acceleration and I can
it's really the force that this bar puts
on that mass to make it go in a circle
but it's handy to think of it as a force
if what I'm interested in is the force
the other get better let's go back to
the old really simple demonstration this
thing going around constant speed
I am definitely there's definitely a
tension in the string and I am pulling
attention is inward right that tension
causes an acceleration of our theta dot
squared and that acceleration is inward
but it's easy to fight if but if you ask
me you know come on Kim quick tell me
what's the tension in the string I just
say that's easy
mr theta dot squared centrifugal force
okay
they're handy but anytime you get stuck
go back and be really just be really
strict and say what's acceleration and
what's real external forces gravity is
an external force okay the force that
the bar puts on the mass that's a real
force but these other things are just
accelerations all right okay hey perfect
I didn't get to the thing I really
wanted to do so I'll do it next time
that's how I'm going to show you this
thing and I want you to fill out your
muddy cards I'm giving you a couple
minutes so this is a mechanical shaker
you see a movement already and we're
going to talk about that next time